tu es parti j'ai besoin d'aide puis-
je préciser qu'ils viendront tous ici Jane maintenant
nous allons nous étendre à travers cette vallée ici
jusqu'à ce que ce serpent se glisse en vue
et que vos garçons viennent pour vous
n'avez pas besoin d'un flingueur vous  besoin d'un
[ __ ] de régime retourne dans ces petites
maisons mieux oh cher mari il est dans un
mauvais état ça ne vaut pas ta vie
Jane ma vie ne vaut pas ta préoccupation
n'a pas été depuis des années
je parie que le jour être habitué à être plus
qu'un  une douzaine de lui
- Warren, tu n'as pas à revenir
Kincaid est en sécurité avec toi toute ma vie Je
dois mettre mon visage devant
donc les garçons de l'évêque sont tous très gros et
gros tu es une telle proie
enceinte viens te protéger et  vos
pièces elle ne sait pas vous ne savez pas la
première chose à son sujet je sais que c'est
criminel
il vaut 2 000 je serais heureux de
doubler ça si vous jugez bon d'apporter du jambon
et de vous mettre en sac vous vous préparez à faire le
très gros  saute mon ami, je vais même
avoir assez de puissance de feu ici pour commencer
une autre guerre
menée au soleil sur votre s  tory
pas grand soleil de mon histoire je suis peut être un
hors la loi mais je tue pas des petits enfants
ouais mais Jane si je te dis qu'est ce qu'il
me reste
oui mon enfant